Spent the last little while
Fixing my bike
Check these breaks out
Check out how bad these were
Please hear what
Ideapad should look like
And I'm Tom
Poem
These were what I pulled off the truck
And if you Lucky
You can see here
This matter was
Totally scraping off
As opposed to what it should look like there
And then I found the culprit looks like the spring that holds them on
Porsche
Totally twisted over
It's really a good thing that I found this
I need the brakes for bad but I didn't know there were this bad
Turns out that I don't have a
Spur spring but I have a spare set of brakes
You're gonna have to
The trying to find a bike shop around it might be able to
Help me find us
Spring
So that I can replace the brakes
Impossible I think I'll just redo the brakes on both sides and by 2
Two replacements that by now gonna head out gonna get some lunch
Oh is this a vegetarian
Animal for bed
To eat or to bring
I know that we've
Entertainment
Digitaria
Desires
The wall the wall
Layout right
So the world is
Circulates all
Soul City so where are we now this is a 711
And this right here I getting
Early there is a fantastic mango smoothie
We're going to now
This is good this is great
This is this is this what is this one is this one is half Mango half that's right I think this is the
How Mango Mango
Sugar Mango
Eager beaver
Every city has a national
Mishmash
Some specialise in
What
Candles
Some specialise in little
Handmade trinkets like in Japan some
Have wood or bamboo products this one
This is nice
I can put this on the tripod
Make everything smell quite fighter
Woody
I was saying to them
As a Traveler like me I don't have any temptation to buy anything that I don't need
Gifts any truck it's a little stuff it's literally
Canopy
Maybe like I don't want to take it it's late I cannot take sorry
Can I take the pill for 2 hour much I might watch it
Sorry I cannot text the ukulele
Is it normally like
Clear blue
Typhoon it had it had its way
Fishing boat
Oh yeah yeah her over there
Normally
On the road yet again or headed to a if that a dependent
Nuclear power plant it's just a idle do you know how percent
And it's only gonna punch people
Yeah so was this the cool and
Releases for the nuclear power plant
So over here that
Nuclear power plant is over here I can
There's
A duct where all the water they used to cool
All the new killer
Nicolas plants
Is coming on this river in
Flowing out of there
The Open ocean
Amazing how much water they need to
Call that thing
Back in Kent Place
We're going to wrap up the day I've got to go back to my hotel over there but before I do I forgot to tell you
Prince the
Guiding theme of the second half of
This day was
Getting my brakes fixed too I'm the trunk
And I noticed I never
You want the Giants
I store here and it was a small place in the
This area isn't too big
Console
They didn't have the disc brakes
Hello I'd like to
We break style
I did have
My spring which was bent in
Sorted and I was able to
Band
That piece
Our and install those new pads and bad
Break area so
I think when I get to the next city
Which is actually through the mountains
A couple of days right
Away I'm gonna stop and we're gonna get the new caliper
And new brakes
For us
For both sides except for the new brakes on Wednesday
Why I get to that location still have a pretty heavy
Couple of days ride
I get there but should be ok
I'll just make sure go wash my brakes in
Anda bien
Web
How they're doing but yeah
I'll get back on the road tomorrow
And I think
That instead of riding around the
Southern tip
Gonna ride
Can bring tomorrow
And I will go to kentane
And will spend one more day on the west side
Animal roundabout
Decide
I was intending the roundabout to the E
Tomorrow
Biter
Annie Express
Desire
For me to visit can't thanks So tomorrow
Is gonna be in a honey so
Because Annie said hi I should definitely
Stopping can bring and spend a day in Kempton
So tomorrow we gonna go to Kent thing
And that is
Is a very touristy very beautiful city
And hopefully the weather will co-operate
And all will be well
I'll see you tomorrow
Next time I'm the jail vlog
So we're gonna stop accounting
Spend the day there
I am in fro
Amor phasing
This dog
A little preview for when I do my ride